vous êtes un homme comblé parce qu'on
peut voir partout à télévision dans 5ème
branche chouchou le bonheur le cyclone
la mer j'en passe j'ai un peu
l'impression que vous vivez votre âge
d'or est-ce que c'est un peu votre
impression aussi ben je dirais que oui
mais c'est surtout que je me comparerai
peut-être à une abeille qui butine plein
de fleurs alors je suis sur toutes
sortes d'affaires qui me permettent
d'aller chercher du miel un peu partout
le mardi c'est de porter chinois le
poulet c'est le jeudi moi c'est de vivre
des expériences parce que tu d'abord
je serais resté animateur parce que
j'étais animateur de quiz dans ma vie
mais je serais resté animateur je serais
beaucoup plus riche que ce que je ne
suis là mais alors moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de jouer puis de
vivre des trucs différents
retour en arrière vous avez été refusé
quatre fois à l'École nationale de
théâtre vous avez suivi des cours à
lucane quand même est-ce que le mot
persévérance et le mot clé dans votre
carrière oui parce que les gens par
exemple avec qui j'ai étudié à lucasme
il y avait des gens qui avaient du
talent mettons comme moi puis il y avait
des gens qui avaient beaucoup plus de
talents il y en avait comme ça
puis j'ai juste été chanceux dans la vie
puis j'ai fait beaucoup oui j'ai
persisté j'ai persisté
à l'École Nationale il faut
vous êtes né à Granby semble-t-il que
votre mère voulait rien savoir de vos
rêves de devenir comédien ma mère est le
sud que j'étudiante théâtre quand j'ai
eu presque fini d'étudier en théâtre
j'ai caché ça tout au long quand j'ai
dit à ma mère c'est ça que je faisais
elle m'a pas parlé pendant un an et demi
un ennemi ça a été très difficile parce
qu'il fallait qu'elle avale quelque
chose qui n'est pas de bon sens
unique le persévérant je parlais de luxe
de courageux bah oui parce que dans fait
divers vous avez joué un propriétaire de
camping de nudiste et dans les designate
mais le représentation on vous voit dans
votre plus simple appareil comment
avez-vous vaincu votre gêne moi j'ai pas
de pudeur par rapport à ça si je
m'explique parce qu'il y avait pas
d'acte sexuel
s'il y avait eu là j'aurais peut-être eu
une retenue une gêne pas à l'aise avec
même si ces chantages pas sûr
j'aurais pas été bien retenons le mot
d'ordre
non mais le type de revues dont il est
plus agréable de regarder les images que
de lire il y a 30 ans presque jour pour
jour vous aligner pour la toute première
fois la guerre des clans on vous voyait
faire le grand écart la split ouais avec
le recul c'est une bonne idée d'animer
la garde des clans parce que ça vous a
vraiment collé à la peau ah ça a été ça
a été magnifique c'était une expérience
extraordinaire où je pouvais rallier par
exemple ce que je vivais avec la Ligue
Nationale d'Improvisation ou et de qui
ça devient deux mondes étranges alors
l'impro ce qu'on dit c'est que tu es
dans le regard de l'autre parce que je
vois lire dans le regard de l'autre
quand j'improvise quand on se tourne
pour commencer improvisé j'ai aucune
idée de ce que l'autre dans sa tête puis
l'autre aucune idée de ce que j'ai dans
la mienne mais si on se regarde dans les
yeux je fais je sais tout de suite ah ok
elle ou il a une idée j'en ai une ou à
la part de peur et ça j'ai appliqué ça à
la guerre des classes bien que pour
chaque concurrent qui sont venu je les
ai toujours regardé dans les yeux et je
voyais si il ou elles étaient bien où
ils étaient pas bien donc c'était
nourrissant c'est à dire que je suis pas
juste en train de poser des questions
puis je serai ça au tableau ça allait
plus loin que ça la question du public
êtes-vous encore capable de faire la
suite oui mais je mange plus
je te ramène là pour vos 65 ans c'est
très bientôt dans quelques semaines vous
avez vendu votre maison à Granby et avec
un concept d'émission assez particulier
vous allez partir en van en VR pour
faire le tour de l'Amérique ça vous fait
pas un peu peur de ne plus avoir de
maison et de juste d'être pas du tout
non non c'est magnifique on était dans
la montagne de chauffeur puis on s'est
défait de ça on a vécu 22 ans là puis là
ce qui est difficile pour nous c'est que
ben je dis ça de moins en moins c'est
qu'on avait un entrepôt avec toutes nos
affaires puis là on se défait de tout on
donne toutes il va nous rester quatre
assiette quatre fourchettes 4 cuillères
quatre tasses le minimum donc c'est
comme ça qu'on veut vivre en simplicité
on avait un autre VR qu'on s'est défait
et on a pensé celui-là en fonction d'en
faire un ministre studio qui nous
permettrait de de faire notre projet
comme tel c'est 111 médias donc on va
faire ça ensemble les trois notre chatte
puis moi puis on verra où est-ce que ça
nous mène lucsonner s'annonce fascinante
pour vous merci beaucoup c'est moi qui
vous remercie